do you need a new car key and remote for
your ford mustang i've got a solution
for you that can save you big money over
the prices car dealerships are charging
and the best thing is you only need one
key to program up to four keys for your
vehicles now i called around and was
quoted over 280
for new car key if you're tired of
rip-off car dealership prices smash the
like button to help youtube share this
video with others visit tomsky.com to
see the many vehicles we can help
program new car keys and remotes for
using the simple key programmer is super
easy place your order and within a few
days
your simple key programmer will arrive
in the mail with one key
if you need additional keys you can
order those through tom's key as well
the first thing you need to do is get
your new key cut to match your existing
one before leaving the locksmith check
that your newly cut key works both ways
turn it over
you find occasionally they don't work
like this key
so you want to go back in get them to
fix it
it's important for you to know there are
two parts to programming your key
first the chip to allow the key to start
the engine and second to program the
buttons to lock and unlock the doors
let's get started by programming the key
to start the engine first thing we got
to do is get this cable plugged into the
obd2 port right down here
remove the security label from your
programmer find your vehicle in the
instruction booklet and turn to the
primary dial position a few vehicles
have a secondary position if the first
one doesn't work set the simple key
programmer to the position for your
vehicle
programming will take about 10 minutes
if the weather's hot roll down some
windows because the doors need to stay
closed and the vehicle turned off during
programming also turn off the lights the
heating or cooling the radio
anything else so you don't drain the
vehicle battery insert the new key you
just had cut and turn it two clicks to
the on position don't start the engine
but the dashboard will light up plug the
programmer into the extension cable it
may take a little bit of force
use care not to push the button on the
end while you're plugging it in press
the button on the end of the programmer
to begin the key programming process
programmer will beep briefly to let you
know programming has started wait 10
minutes for the programming to finish
you might want to set a timer you might
consider if you want to pick up a tile
key finder and make sure you never lose
your car keys this is also a great time
to set up the app it's really simple get
in there and get started
okay hear the beeping unplug the
programmer remove the key from the
ignition then test your new key by
starting the engine
if it didn't work repeat the procedure
again
there are also troubleshooting
instructions inside the owner's manual
it includes a number of suggestions to
solve problems now that we've programmed
the key to work it's time to program the
buttons press unlock on the driver's
door turn the ignition from off to on
eight times within 10 seconds
leaving it in the on position on the
eighth time and insert your key one
two
three
four
five
8.
the door locks will cycle to let you
know the vehicle is ready to program new
remotes leaving the key in the ignition
press any button on the first remote
this is probably the key you already
have in the ignition the door locks will
cycle letting you know the remote is
programmed then press any button on each
remote the locks will cycle confirming
each remote is programmed to your
vehicle
once all remotes are paired remove the
key from the ignition to exit
programming mode test all remotes to
ensure they are working
if any are not working repeat the
procedure
if you're running into problems remember
we provide exceptional customer service
we recommend you start by looking in
your instruction manual
at the frequently asked questions
section the simple key programmer we
sell at tom's key company makes it super
easy to program a new key and remote
buttons for your vehicle including ford
mustang 2005 through 2014. this process
works for many ford lincoln and mercury
vehicles even ones with keys and remotes
like this
find the full list on tomsky.com if
somehow it doesn't work for your vehicle
reach out to us
via email help tomsky.com if we still
can't solve your problem no worries our
full money back guarantee has you
covered send everything back in its
original packaging and you'll get your
money refunded i really appreciate it if
you subscribe to the channel and like
the video that really does help youtube
let others know that we're making videos
that people find helpful please leave a
comment on this video about your
experience with tom's key company so
other people know how it worked for you
visit tomsky.com find your ford mustang
and place an order for the simple key
programmer kit you'll be programming
that new key soon thanks and have a
great day